Did you ever realize while you were,
while you were in the middle of this,
especially in the beginning,
the early days,
that this was,
that you guys had,
especially with van Halen in the early days,
you guys had a massive impact on culture.
Where you guys aware of that?
Like while it was happening,
how,
I mean when I was in high school,
I graduated in 1985 and you guys were the shit.
My girlfriend,
my sister's rather boyfriends,
uh,
my sister's boyfriend's license.
I am the sand tray.
I'm the soundtrack to your whole,
I get this now.
Absolutely.
I mean,
what was that?
That the gym was intentional.
It was intentional.
I can tell you now the van Halen knew it but can't articulate it.
But right there instrumentalists.
Here comes the funny joke words M my thing,
right?
You understood the words in my thing.
So you realized that while it was happening.
Well,
your end game depends on how you started.
It's like chess.
And we began very early on identifying that there's a whole lot of different
neighborhoods and southern California.
I knew this from being with my dad,
all of his patients,
whereas like a Benetton ad com.
Yeah.
You know,
that's part of the beauty of passive data.
You got everybody.
Okay.
And um,
okay.
The way you play at the birthday party in the Spanish speaking neighborhood,
old rally Santana,
you got to change.
You've we bro.
Yeah.
It's different than what we're going to play for the surfers out of Venice
beach.
That's Aerosmith stuff.
Uh,
you know,
and do like this.
And then you have the working man okay.
Out in San Bernardino,
that Zz top
right.
Subtle but important genius is in the details and how you interact with that
crowd.
In between.
We would play out in Pomona at a biker bar.
Guy got killed right in front of us and we finished the song.
What happened?
A couple of bike bike gangs went at it and uh,
there was a scrap and when everybody cleared out,
there was a fellow right in the middle of the floor.
Next night we came back,
vengeance had been sworn,
there were police Chevy where we pulled the amps out from the wall so we could
hide behind the amps.
And
seventies there was a mighty task.
Wow.
And we played on the Queen Elizabeth for remotely fancy.
Oh my God.
I remember sitting in that ballroom at four in the morning in the days when we
carried our own equipment and stuff and thinking of all the people who had been
in there and everybody who'd perform there and so forth.
And dozens and dozens of places know that we're all a little bit different.
And our,
our thing was that we could play anywhere we had to otherwise,
uh,
we had feed ourselves.
All right.
And that meant five 45 minutes sets a night,
five,
six nights.
If you could get it.
And we would ping pong all over the Southland anywhere we could drive for two
hours,
two hours north,
south or east is how we would do in every neighborhood was a little different.
And that shows up in the music,
you know,
now you can take a look at something like dance the night away or Jamie's
crying.
There's a,
there's a Latino influence in that.
Okay.
Do,
do,
that's Ricky Ricardo people say,
what's your favorite Cuban expecting me to name a cigar.
I say Ricky Ricardo,
but in the ditch,
Rumba,
Rumba to touch a dud to now you're thinking about it,
you go yeah,
and kid.
And if he was in a dance the night away,
the middle break is all cha-cha chotchkies stuff,
Leah,
because here this is,
you know,
are you're surrounded by Hispanic culture here and we had heavy metal
influences.
Okay.
We had a super wealthy stuff.
So you have to be able to move to acoustic.
You gotta be able to ease up if you get hired for a wedding.
And more importantly,
perhaps,
you know,
artists to artists.
I don't know Springsteen better during the song or in between.
Careful.
We're going to the Broadway show.
Yeah,
that's about a $12,000 ticket now.
And I'm guessing,
I'm guessing before tee shirt.
And,
uh,
I'm guessing that,
I haven't seen the whole show.
I saw some of it on Netflix and the very pivot of it is the in between songs.
Yeah.
The songs are almost secondary.
You know,
they're almost peripheral to his narration in his descriptions and his poetry.
Well,
he sets a deep guy.
Like you have to hear the in between stuff.
You want to hear him brewed,
you want to hear him talk,
you want to hear him think about things.
Yes.
And where do you learn that or dealing that
already have,
I'm going to count to 30,000 Joe hours and hours and hours and when we're done
you'll be able to,
you know,
Joe,
that's not a good Springsteen.
You know,
you're a good man.
Jo.
What I was trying to get at was like,
does it ever freak you out?
Like when you ever alone and you think about what you guys did and what you've
done in your career,
does it ever freak you out?
But the impact that you've had,
that if you looked at the amount of human beings that have had the kind of
impact that you've had,
the tiniest,
tiniest fraction of a percent,
like the amount of human beings that can relate to your personal life
experiences.
Paraphrase the James Brown movie,
there's two of them.
Both of them were helpful,
hopefully produced by Jagger.
Okay.
And,
uh,
he does an interview.
He goes down a little bit of me in every record you hear.
Oh yeah.
He's in the DNA is a little bit of David Lee Roth in there.
Yeah,
there's a little bit,
whenever,
when you see videos today,
it doesn't matter if it's hip hop,
doesn't matter if it's rock and roll.
It doesn't matter if it's classic or pit bull.
Can you dig?
There's a lead.
You can trace it back if follow.
Right.
And it's not a,
I don't think of it as impact.
That's a result.
What's the verb?
Contribution.
Yeah.
At family reunions,
whatever we go around,
everybody picks a word.
And,
uh,
my favorite word ever was to contribution.
Did you try,
you know,
go climb the tree.
Here's my favorite poem.
I saw it inscribed on a rock by an anonymous poet at the base.
Just sort of base camp at Everest.
Go climb the treasure mountain.
Do not return empty handed.
Where are you now?
Mm.
Ooh.
Ooh,
Yeah.
That's some gps shit.